how's it going everybody Aaron Sampson
here with Erte what up we uh we're
playing a ton of Fallout 76 last night
yeah you guys went pretty late huh like
like three four hours or as long as the
beta lasted I guess because I went a
little earlier we went wait until the UH
this said you got you got to go home guy
forced you out of the game we're hoping
there's going to be a nuke or something
at the end of it but yeah just kicked us
out uh coming in today and we got a lot
of Halloween events um I knew a blackout
has started their Halloween event for
call of duty and fortnight is now well
fortnight is like the yeah Battle Royale
game right now kind of knew about fort
nightmares and I'm gonna switch this
over so you can switch that over I'm
gonna launch this it should in theory
launch the trailer hey y'all I thank you
all of you guys that are tuning yes yes
windows yes it's okay thank you guys all
for tuning in take a spotlight live
Monday to Friday 11:00 a.m. tomorrow is
actually gonna be a little earlier than
normal I can't say why other than you
should come hang out earlier and or
subscribe if you haven't because that
way you'll know for sure
also because embargoes yeah exactly just
know that there's embargoes that's all
you need to know you can probably guess
so hopefully this does what it did at my
desk earlier
I gotta say the the pets are kind of
awesome in this game right now I really
wish there was more oh I totally played
I was so sure it was gonna play anyways
for nightmares and six-shooter yep
so new gun you can transform your
appearance by dealing damage or
outlasting other players with the first
ever reactive dead fire outfit dark
shadow picks I'm not buying that you
know there's an emote though now we're
gonna check out as we get into this mode
I'd actually like to talk about oh here
you go here we go
turn up the mic
oh damn
[Music]
so it appears there are zombies and all
that stuff what are they doing on the
map are they bringing in elements from
saved like the splash screen yeah yeah
so there's like there's sport nightmare
challenges so here's part one their cube
monsters it's what they're called
deal damage with assault rifles or
pistols to keep monsters visit a
corrupted area in different matches
dance in different in front of different
gargoyles if you want to know about that
Dave did a guide ready
so that's on gamespot comm we do guys
every week by the way for the 49 channel
I guess you get this sweet little oh
that was for something else oh that was
for a part for man only part for is any
good even had to to train shadow says
save the world in Battle Royale
alright hear me out save the world had
some really interesting ideas that they
could bring into battle royale such as
monster chess they were gold chess that
were actually monsters Borderlands 2 did
this with like chess midgets epic chess
midgets oh you can all it's not even a
time mode it would be hilarious if you
had to watch out before you actually
open a gold chest because it might chase
you across the map and try and kill you
like save the world also had abilities
so they could bring back in like mantis
jump and and throwing stars and like
forward especially fortification so you
could fortify structures that you built
and save the world and I feel like
that'd be a great pick up put up a tower
fortify it so yeah save the world has
potential it at least has potential more
people are playing this version and to
your point though and I don't know I'd
argue that somehow Cod found a way to do
it before these guys did or maybe they
were just planning it all along for
Halloween but you know now there's
essentially zombies right in the on the
map Allah what blackout has now yeah if
you know chat if you guys want to talk
about for tonight versus blackout I'd
love to have that conversation because
everybody's taking note will they start
taking note because the pub G and then
fortnight build on the same engine as
gee pretty much a highway but right now
I was taking screenshots oh no another
battle royale news today a battle field
said that they're delaying their battle
royale it's not gonna be a launch so
more than one back at loot huh like
acceptance oh yeah the cubes oh the bus
is different too yeah Kevin's coming
back to life we're gonna die we're just
gonna go there and die I am NOT gonna
lie like I think I've been I got into
fortnight when somebody out stop
covering for tonight in this office and
I don't regret it
I actually think this has been hotel
people one of my favorite games in a
while and I'm not ashamed to say it yeah
I think it has a really good building
battle system it's got one of the best
unlocked trees in the industry right now
it's totally not greedy oh I got him oh
are you doing solos to be fair I play
yeah we got one though I should've never
went there and I don't know why I went
there
crime saying black hats more of a pub
gee yeah I agree with that to some
degree only because you know there's
obviously no building and like the menus
are very like similar I guess or like
what you would do like looting wise and
stuff like that but shooting mechanics
wise not so much hate crime I would say
it's a bigger threat to pubsey for sure
like it's more of the military tactical
shooter Battle Royale and its mechanics
are smoother and more solid they're less
like a tactical simulation than then pub
G like some people might still like pub
G because the guns all handle way
differently and in Call of Duty weapons
have a much narrower range for how they
handle like generally you pick up a gun
a call duty and the bullets go where you
want them to go bad first game yeah
that's fine
it could have went a lot worse that guy
should have killed me the guy grenaded
what are your thoughts about finding out
that the battle royale for battlefield
is like so far away like it's next year
right do you got on the way in to work
today I was reading over the battlefield
5 Road map and full disclosure like I've
I played alpha beta and I've played
three campaign missions war stories but
that that read like a like an early
access title to me oh yeah there's so
much a content that's not happening
right at launch they're adding in rush
later they're adding in bigger tank
battles later they're adding in battle
royale later which is weird right
because they already delayed I'm sorry
I'm trying to like do two things at one
time
I think I got yeah sorry
continue with your point no I managed I
just battlefield 5 I mean they're gonna
get to the battle royale game late I
hope it's because they're trying to make
it good but that game is there's got to
be a story behind the development of
that game because the roadmap read more
like an early access title and we still
don't really know fully what's there at
launch it's just it's odd at this point
I digress yeah I mean it is worrisome
though for sure like if you're a
battlefield fan is Krum wants to know
what you guys think of the blackout send
rate controversy the tick rate oh the
frame rate have you see did you hear
about that that like during the beta it
was like 60 Hertz you know it's like 20
or 30 at best so the concern is that the
game isn't actually registering your
bullets properly that's part of it I
believe yeah I mean I haven't played it
though at worse well I played it early
but I don't think I've been I've
experienced it because I haven't been
playing it as of late which is when I
started hearing about the change for
those of you just joining us we're
playing fortnight nightmares fort
nightmares or nightmares which is their
Halloween event blackout also has their
holiday there
oh they do have saved the world elements
in here now I'm happy do you get to kill
200 oh they give Dooley's though oh I
think it's the things give me shields
that's cool
oh and you can kill the cube that's like
spawning this stuff I'm instantly
interested because I actually didn't
like save the world here's what that
does it stops it from spawning anything
Jeff is asking if we're gonna have a
stream for Red Dead Redemption - I think
you can bet on that when our one arm
embargo lifts oh what is that oh it's a
Halloween themed rocket launcher let's
go Garfield saying people will say that
Cod copy oh hey hey hey hey pom-pom chat
I got him nice I don't like that I'm
trying to just you know fight some cute
monsters this guy's being a jerk that's
what you get for playing solos day
that's fine
you just killed that man with a pumpkin
I'd like to not under underscore that
pumpkin and rocket launcher it laughs as
it goes out yes oh there's zombies here
now to be fair save the world had
zombies before so I got a pretty decent
loot from what
I'm [ __ ] killing me guys hopefully no
one comes and bothers me you know just
farming cute monsters trying to get an
objective done I'm still curious
welcome zap TV Krystal first time
joining the stream welcome for tuning in
we're playing some fort nightmares from
fort night
oh you game shield when you kill the
cute monsters oh nice so okay blew that
up and it just dropped it
so that kind of levels the playing field
of another another player gets to drop
unto you potentially if you're gaining
shield as you're shooting it we are
playing battle royale
looks like they've taken some
save-the-world elements and put them in
this game which is awesome oh there's a
p90 yeah let's get that our smg's good
again I feel like they're really good
and they were not good it needs to be
but it's fine alright I'm gonna go kill
some more keep monsters I'm here just P
being you know Oh someone else killed
something here or I don't recall doing
any of this right here
Matthew's waiting for the download on
switch oh nice how do you like for not
on switch I hear mixed I can't I from
what I've seen I don't know how I would
be able to tolerate that but that's me
it looked pretty janky from what I
remember seeing but it's been a while so
maybe it's like slightly more optimized
oh what is that oh no it's just a normal
day I'm really accurate when they're
slow Karen I just want you to know that
it helps and zombies are I know for
being slow who AR
yeah you'd hit that tree I think one
thing that's kind of interesting because
we've been covering the hunt challenge
and the weekly challenges in fortnight
the challenges have skewed a lot more
RNG this season which is actually meant
that it took us it's taken us now more
like six hours instead of three hours to
complete the challenges each week they
just wanted you to play the game
curious how people feel about that cuz
it feels in some ways more fair but in
other ways I don't know like I haven't
found a sniper rifle in weeks and I
still have a challenge from like week to
go like bolt-action yeah like I got no
way to actually make it happen other
than trying to farm vending machines
I know grand ol time right now I like
how the dog gets angry when you start
shooting
we got excitement in the chat for Red
Dead rightfully so yeah gonna be a big
one it's gonna be a big one and then uh
are you excited for that game cuz I
don't really I personally don't care
rigid yeah it's a it's probably the best
Western game that you're gonna play in a
long time that's fair that was a safe
line you just took I I'm a little biased
I was never really into westerns but I
I'm in the shooters so I have a
complicated relationship with Rockstar
Games because they don't necessarily
make good shooters they've been a little
bit too hand-holding in my opinion over
the years but yeah but that's not what
that game is about right and it also
makes it more accessible for a lot of
people so I think the fair the safe that
would be that you're probably looking at
you're probably looking at like a really
good Western and a really good rockstar
game no we gotta go given given their
history at our games oh that's a person
Dwain uh yeah we definitely a question
was have we played the 76 beta we played
when streamed it for a couple hours last
night that's on VOD on our YouTube
channel it's interesting it
it was polarizing in our office I think
we all had pretty different takes on it
depending on where we were coming from
mechanically I wasn't impressed with it
again like coming from a shooter
perspective and as someone who played
fallout 4 primarily as a shooter
I don't think Bethesda can get away with
that level of jank anymore they they
need to like make their games way less
bulky if they're gonna rely on that
aspect of it but people in the office
lovely cool hey there's that campfire oh
god leave me alone
I'm glad you're playing and people in
the office who were fans of Fallout
really enjoy the exploration aspects of
it oh no that was solo damn it seeing
harden yourself say that was me six life
kill him
yes zombies got my revenge yes sir there
was a lot of different opinions
depending on where you're coming for in
76 I after four hours I wasn't super
impressed I think it's we need to
explore a lot more of it to kind of see
because they're leaning on exploration
and exploration leans on combat in
combat is not a strength of Bethesda
well I will say though from because I
had mentioned to you too as well like
that there there seems to be a pretty
positive response at least like when you
look at their Twitter only because I
feel like for those people one they're
already but there's a fallout fans right
but two I think the thing that either
will help or not help 70 fallout 76 is
like do you have a squad you're playing
with because if you're if you have a
squad you're playing with that you're
like you know they're like hey I'm gonna
hop on you're probably gonna hop on too
and that you know obvious is a
multiplayer game but even with destiny
right like when you have people to play
with that game is more fun right so I
think for me if I was to even think
about playing for 76 I'd have to have at
least two or three friends that I could
rely
reliably play with like at least once or
twice a week that would then encourage
me to then get on because you're more
like you're hanging out with your
friends and like I saw like some people
were like end of the day in beta playing
music together with my friends and like
that was a moment for them right but not
everyone's gonna have that moment and
like if you're I don't know if some of
that jegging is deters you then yeah
then you know and it's hard to write
because we're about to hit it like a
couple more big games this year and
people can only really afford so many
games in the year right I just gonna I
don't know I think a lot of people were
buying gonna buy read dead
I would assume but you know yeah I mean
c76 also has because it's a live game
they've got if they attract like a
decent initial audience they have time
to work on it and again we got into one
server for four hours last night and it
wasn't the most stable server so it you
know take it from what it was it was it
was definitely like a technical test
mm-hmm and they can do a lot potentially
between now and just launching it oh
those are balance pad Sam
there's just some things that I'm not
okay with anymore though like loading
into buildings with longboat Obama this
is your favorite right like why are we
loading into buildings in 2018 it's just
not something that should still exist
and and to your point bringing people
together they do have public events they
do appear on the map and they do have
story elements they seem to pull people
together we got a new couple like pvp
slap fights last night and we actually
won one or two or we got the other
player to like agree to fight us so it
was like you
yeah decorations um let me leave it at
this it has potential it's not there yet
for sure that's fair I mean it is beta
although how much do you think that game
will actually change in the next like
you know month or so cuz it comes out in
November right yeah I think if they
really nail it down it feels like it's
launching as early access I don't know
where this weird arrow where you don't
really know what state of games
launching in like is this a game
is this a full-price game is this an
early access game is this a live game
where you don't really know how it's
gonna work and you're gonna figure it
out as you go so I don't know
fallout 76 feels like it's looking for
its identity it's not it's not quite
there yet
and I don't I don't think in the next
month they're gonna find it but they
feel there's like a very good chance
that'll hone in as they go Judy's a six
suit I'm gonna die yep
then you two that that little Jackyl
winner yeah he earned it with those sick
pumpkin pajamas he know he port afforded
me - oh he's gonna die - the up is he
gonna die - those zombies yeah if he
does that'd be the second time close its
close I loved that dog yeah the dogs the
best boy Ricardo you're at school right
now pay attention in class
yeah we don't uh it's one of those
things where I don't want to know that
you're doing that and if you do you're
definitely not telling the teacher our
names because it's not our fault let's
see if that is even up I was gonna try
to check the shop this is the pumpkin
pajamas but they've actually like banned
I mean they never really liked phones in
schools but they definitely ban phones
in schools cuz the fortnight oh yeah I'm
replaces yeah definitely or night is a
problem only because you can play it on
mobile to like see the thing was at
least back in the day oh hi
like back in the day you know even if
you had a cell phone at best you had
snake or something silly like that or
Tetris where you know hell we put that I
put that on my TI 86 I had Tetris and
like some other stuff but I mean you
couldn't play like a game game now it's
like there's so many games you could
play on mobile okay I think the only
thing we were doing on TI 86 is was
spelling boobs backwards that that was
it that was sure that was all we did
with those things
didn't they cause like a hundred bucks
back in the day James like 80 bucks
something like that something is saying
I think there's still that expensive
though I should have looked at those
challenges we're just going to try to
kill those things even though I know I
think drew Papp
not not so happy that I was just killing
zombies but I was having a good time and
I was doing a challenge you know got a
shout out from Montreal nice how's the
weather would you say you're a Canadiens
fan zap TV crystal says he was just
playing snake oh really
yeah that's true you could also play
Tetris on I couldn't hear yeah you could
do Tetris there's a bunch of stuff
back in the day yeah I'm dating myself
by saying that but you know alright that
guy's going to lazy fortnight this guy's
good job in here though I think I've
said this before in stream I have I have
kids and I take them places and those
places usually have other kids playing
for tonight playing for tonight you
shouldn't be playing for tonight so we
went to the Science Museum there's a kid
on the Science Museum computer playing
for tonight really went to the puppy
installed it in there oh yeah these kids
are smart eni's days that's crazy
Public Library there was a kid who
managed to get fortnight on the public
library computer playground there were
kids like separating themselves into who
doesn't doesn't play for at night
yeah I mean it's definitely a phenomenon
like for better for worse like I got in
a plane or I was in line for a plane and
the two kids behind me one had a they
both had like like iPad or tablets and
they were both playing for a night just
like alright it's pretty insane um
honestly like I think I can't look at
SLAC right now John Luke this game
deserves it in my opinion though I think
these guys did an incredible thing with
their original launch a save the world
which we actually didn't give that good
overview - they brought four okay you
know what they turn this thing on a dime
Aaron give me a favorite you're gonna
ride solo for a second okay you can mute
my mic and then you're gonna just slide
this alright you're gonna see how less
good I play than Taye
I'm just gonna slide over to tase right
here how's it going everybody I'm flying
solo and I'm a 50 V 50 guy actually this
is one of my favorite Battlefield games
in a while and I will stand by that
because as soon as they got big team
battle on this game I never went back to
battle royale which is one of the
reasons why I actually like fortnight
all right Oh taste keybindings
and a guy I don't know I'm just go over
here and shoot a Cuban hope this goes
well for me all right oh they're gonna
put in the redeploy of gliders which i
think is really cool that came from
soaring 50s basically lets people oh god
your key bindings are totally different
from monta so being able to redeploy
your glider is really cool because it
lets you get across the map super fast
and also you die way less often when
people knock out ramps from under you
let's go fight some zombies not doing a
this solo shenanigans we'll get a some
uh some nice weekly challenge points no
other player big team battle a lot of
fun and playground I'm glad you agree
with me crime I think that's worth that
the interesting thing about a big team
battle in for Knight is you can actually
kind of make a class for yourself like
you can actually play as a support you
can support your team with heels with
building oh man alright and see squad's
practice joes disco domination squad
solo and duos oh a sad face
there's no 50s this week alright in that
case we're gonna run around and kill
more zombies
but yeah the 50 v50 lets you play as a
support player like you can you can heal
people fortify your team go save people
it's it's in my opinion the best way to
play shoutout from Montenegro thanks for
joining us
Anvil's getting the conversation going
about Red Dead online do any of you guys
played GTA online and are you interested
in Red Dead multiplayer online for
reddit I'm I'm more than assuming that's
the case also if you manage to get into
the fallout 76 beta last night we played
a bunch of that and we would like to
hear thoughts on it or if you want to
talk about blackout
we played plenty of blackout in this
office they started doing their
Halloween event - we'll see where they
end up they really need to get their
progression system in line compared to
fortnight let's go uh I don't know this
might be suicidal but I kinda want to
see what's up with Kevin and the island
splitting so let's go check it out there
was a unconfirmed rumors lately that
Kevin in the island has something like
six stages so now that these the Kevin
cube story is progressing we might
actually start seeing that story move
it's like the island doesn't seem to be
floating anymore it's just here
wonderfully shot Kevin at this point and
it would eject these players all right
let's get out of here nope not going to
tilt it has a bad idea for somebody who
plays 50s disco domination he's like 50
v50 with 30 30 yeah to be honest I
always kind of thought 50 was a little
bit too much like it would actually be
better if it was smaller more smaller
teams which they've done in the past
kind of do the planetside thing where
you're fighting another team and then a
third faction shows up and you gotta
decide if you want to keep fighting or
bail okay
fair warning this will probably not go
well for me I usually play 50s and I
don't know what taste key bindings are
just try and monitor chat at the same
time smg's then you get any more used to
love SMGs and they made them not good
the building elements in foreign aid is
ridiculous I would say that it actually
in a weird wave makes this game have a
really high skill threshold at the upper
end way more than than pop G and some
other games like the people who are
really good at before tonight are
ridiculously way better than you are
whereas in pub G you might be able to
catch up to them in a game like this
you're not gonna win against top layers
unless you know how to build and you
know how to build really fast all right
where we off to con I'm gonna go fight
some monsters yep we don't die
yeah all right
didn't die that's good like building a
ramp to the moon you're gonna see a lot
more ramps actually now that the game
has put in glider redeploy the main
strategy is essentially oh there's the
revolver does this work
revolver let's go find some monsters and
use the revolver be mindful of in a
minute until the circle closes all right
revolver what do you do oh okay you're
good you're good revolver hey I got your
revolver you can have to move in a
minute sure here I'll swap back I don't
hear any are we safe we're kind of safe
yeah we're like a slightly outside of
the circle using a new revolver
so I will be fine
have you just been hunting zombies I'd
killed a player
oh nice and you had the revolver and I
did with the shotgun oh nice
what's it like building a ramp to the
moon yeah so now that you can redeploy
your glider you're gonna see a lot more
of that happening like oh you can
redeploy at any time yeah so like in
storing fifties this strategy is people
just collect wood and then build giant
ramps and basically float across the map
which kind of brought in the fun meta
with the ice trap where people would
trap their own ramps and get people to
slide back down and and die essentially
the dog legit looks like scooby-doo huh
they um they put a lot of work into the
the animals they have like a bunch of
different animations that they do so
when you're if you like look when you
first parachute in the dogs basically
holding on to your backpack for its life
yeah yeah that's awesome I like it a lot
and when you go into a down state the
dog starts trying to guard your body
I've been continually impressed with
four nights like cosmetic additions and
unlock tree one of the cool things about
four nights unlocked trees you can pay
for it once and then like ten bucks for
the season for the season and you can
actually earn enough points in any given
season chug-chug or if you don't get
tempted by other cosmetics you can just
go indefinitely you can earn enough
points to buy every season you can also
buy a season late in the season and
it'll give you all of your progress as
if you have been playing the whole time
so I like how not not greedy of a system
it is it's just really fair the stuff
that you earn is fun the dance moves are
great the cosmetics are like cool
they do make up for with like their
high-end cosmetics or something like
twenty bucks dude there yeah they're
kind of that's a little bit insane to me
but no you don't have to buy them and
they are pretty nuts like the dragon
glider is something shoots really fast
or revolver I'm just gonna say yeah to
be fair you're not exactly Fanning the
hammer what is this
overwatch alright so I think it's
interesting blackout blackout definitely
needs to catch up in terms of coming up
with a good progression system it's so
weird to be playing a Call of Duty game
Call of Duty mode that doesn't have
crazy progression in it so think they
need to take a page from for tonight
dang slurps slurps slurps what could I
do
crimes thinking it should spawn more
difficult monsters as you destroy the
atlas yeah there should be like it would
be cool if there's like a crazy monster
but maybe that's gonna come in time
who knows out of here where is that guy
shooting me from well we got to go
though regardless dang it I hope that's
not okay
so I'm trying to set up for an
appointment with that we have and
they're having problems connecting to it
sadly corporate internet hope there's
that guy shout-out to minecraft game
that game what's going on over there
from downtown I game had people for a
long time nope they're hella short it's
not even getting there a question from
the chat what's the new revolvers name
is that in the menu I don't know it
doesn't time to check right now
oh there's a guy way up top
yeah
nice there's a guy up top though
somebody's saying try the new revolver
without aiming okay nope absolutely
melted good job that guy oh there's
there's your bolt action I said that one
doesn't count actually it held really
yeah oh I'm definitely not a pro yeah I
will uh I will try once we get another
one it'd be cool if it at a
single-player story mode at least
something seasonal play save the world
it's not free though yeah it's not going
free this year actually they just
announced that I don't know if there's a
big enough following for them to really
I'm kind of surprised they're still
putting their time and energy into it
done this though do I think Red Dead
will get a ten I do not know it is up to
the reviewer I was correct
taking see my text yes Alex Laura like
as in like a text message or as in like
lower the mic a little bit for Eric and
you
I just project he's blown out the mic
why not blowing it out with pilot win a
match only killing zombies a dog it's
possible if the person dies to the blue
yeah and you somehow stay in the circle
so it is sort of possible I'm sure
somebody's gonna do it yeah those are
like challenges that streamers do they
like or people will use they used to use
the watch McCollum's to push you back
into the blue yeah shockwave
yeah I forget the term but yeah so the
other thing you owe me all the
challenges I did the other thing that
uh-oh if you're looking for the
challenges we also so we cover those
every week on gamespot if you just look
up week season six week whatever on
gamespot we have a guide on where to
pick up yours your search betweens and
we're doing the hunt challenges and
we'll tell you how to get everything
done I will say a lot of the challenges
in season six are based on random
randomly finding things so it takes a
lot longer now than it used to
yeah like the first week it had like two
campfires and I was like great or like
find a llama that's always good Red Dead
Redemption to gameplay leaked yeah we uh
we're a professional organization and we
do not do that so if somebody does that
there just ain't much we can do about
leaky gameplay there's no gun in here
sick I saw that guy's got p90 it's time
to get what does this work no that
doesn't work
alright the other thing bounces I guess
I honestly can't think of a situation
where I've heard about a developer
actually like not inviting people who
leaked footage anymore they probably do
need to crack down on that a bit though
cuz they send out a lot of kids just a
lot of different random people these
days yeah but I don't know so it's like
two different teams that are probably
tracking that yeah but yes with uh what
you landed here wins minecraft in 49
merging oh those things just spawn now
no nice oh that's a person kind of feel
like this is sort of a minecraft 49
theme for 90s kind of Minecraft in many
ways I mean I'll see if you play save
the world you're doing nothing but
building
- waterspout a huge word for it that
they check those out they must be back
for tonight should have a top down mode
you could probably use the cinematic
tool and show people what that would
look like honestly I think a lot of
people have a hard time with for tonight
because it's got a cartoon exterior but
under the surface is actually a pretty
good shooter and it takes a lot of skill
sometimes devs also leak themselves
intentionally yeah that's true
I mean like I don't have hacked achill
don't have any confirmed examples of
that to point to you but I would not
doubt that it's a probably in the PR
marketing arsenal these days
particularly if they're doing like an
alternate reality style game rock star
band some YouTube accounts well played
I feel bad he's gonna die maybe if you
get two ends I got guns I still died
welcome to fortnight yeah it's cuz
you're not playing big team battle
actually it's not in this week I don't
know I'm gonna do like WOD it's probably
yeah well here's your challenges that's
what you're looking for destroy key
monsters deal damage with assault rifles
or pistols to keep monsters visit a
corrupted area in different matches
dance in front of different gargoyles
just got here can you look at the
tornado I can try to get to the tornado
again no problem
Keeton's asking about people who've
played on all the different consoles is
it because you're thinking about playing
it on a specific one it's been solid on
PC and ps4 that's all I can speak to
I think switch has had mixed results I
don't know where they're at right now
anybody playing on switch and can speak
to if switch is stable and good we're
gonna go try and see what Kevin's up to
you again well you finished the four
challenges seems easy so many of those
challenges now that's just step one and
then step two will be something else
that's been a trend in season six and
some of it you can't control like I
don't I think week two need you to find
different sniper rifles that just
weren't coming up so completing those
challenges just depends on your ability
to find random things sometimes
particularly this season how's it going
Robbie thanks for joining us we are
playing fortnight fortnight mares
Halloween events but we're also down to
talk about fallout 76 beta that we
played a bunch of last night or what
your thoughts are on blackout black ops
4 is mode or the fact that battlefields
battle royale got delayed again won't be
there at launch okay one person says
Eric's not good the other person says
Eric is hacking come on chat get it
together as eric - good there's your uh
your look at the tornado probably died
for this but it's fine so Kevin's back
he spawned an island that Island roamed
around for a couple of weeks and now he
broke out of the island so I don't know
who knows what Kevin is up to now Oh
killed by an enforcer with a glowing
cave Nats all right try to get eleven
kills I'll try to get one kill ones ones
good enough for me it's gonna be like a
roller coaster ride take care of a bunch
of people up front now with a dip of the
roller coaster and we're pretty much
what do you guys think about blackout so
far are people playing blackout I think
so but that thirty Hertz things kind of
lame that is actually a problem today is
simultaneously streaming and also
setting up other streams and events
requests from the look at the item show
okay
I'll do I'll go die roll fest which
would have happened anyways yeah unless
I go fight zombies if Tay dives real
slow head on over to GameSpot and we
actually cover this every week or just
in your Google browser just type in for
night season six comma GameSpot and
every week we put up everything that we
find that's notable in the store and
also do all the season challenges the
weekly challenges for each season and
where to find where to find them how did
you them when you need to there's the
dog doing its thing best boy crime scene
I really enjoyed the block yeah beta but
we'll only buy it if it's sold
separately that was an issue with what
the modern warfare 2 remaster as well
that got ya packaged in and people just
wanted it and they eventually sold it
alone
yeah I eventually but it took a while I
think and I don't even know if they do
it still because part of the draw to get
you to buy that game is that it is there
is blackout right
I don't what do you think tey do you
think oh my god oh he's trying it oh
good good try Internet guy I don't care
not here there's a great compilations on
reddit of people doing that inside of
buildings and people just thinking that
they're actually people yeah just people
T posing next to Halloween decorations
not gonna work on me not in an open
field cuz I also saw him land I'm
surprised he didn't try to take the gun
for me because I failed at picking up
that gun for a long time
I give that guy props for trying
seriously it was a good effort he knew
he was screwed so he went out in style
and in tipo style
is that fun I'm after school right now
what time is it I guess if you're in a
different time zone what like East Coast
could be getting out of school at 3
o'clock right now do you think they're
gonna do black out as a separate mode
down the line boy that's something you
do by all we mean as something like for
the future yeah I mean it seems pretty
successful although they don't have do
they even have microtransactions that in
in that for black out they launched
black out with without even having a
progression tree which they've just put
in now and I think that progression tree
might tie into their call of duty bucks
if it hasn't already I guarantee it will
if I were betting man I would say
they're gonna eventually break out black
out and do its own mode when the sales
drop off for the core game cuz it's a
games of service and the way to do that
is to lower the barrier lower the
barrier to entry you know four nights
free yeah but it's because it has ways
to make money still though yeah but like
they're definitely gonna be looking at
how to make money off black out in the
long run oh definitely
but yeah so yeah I feel like either the
dropping the price of the whole game or
breaking black out into its own separate
download are certainly strong
possibilities in the future 33 months
ago
and we're in the circle so we might as
well just hang out here Gramps is a I'm
more concerned about what will happen to
black out when the next Cod comes yeah
yeah I just don't see them like breaking
that out of like the actual purchase is
really purchased so then like unless
they're okay with having just a
standalone Cod if it was standalone it
could probably survive another college
ad game coming out I don't know like
Call of Duty feels feels like it's on
the decline a bit it's still a hugely
popular title but they took baby steps
in the hero shooter direction with black
ops 4 it still feels a lot like a Call
of Duty game at some point people are
gonna start getting tired of doing the
same thing every year I'm not gonna lie
like I think battlefield 5 is having
trouble beat just because of battlefield
fatigue yet we have a game like World
War 3 that's an early access now though
it's cuz World War 3 is more of an OG
battlefield it's more like a
continuation of battlefield 4 than it is
though like the smaller infantry focused
direction that two more
oh come on
Aaron Singh Aaron Moore saying blackout
is 60 bucks and has a free tier system
for tonight you need to pay $10 each
season it's true but as I point out
before and fortnight you can actually
pay $10 for one season and then play a
reasonable amount and earn enough V
bucks to actually buy every season after
that if you just keep playing so you
don't you can technically pay like 10
dollars for fortnight one time if you
don't get tempted by a sick back bling
and gliders and dance moves free loot
drops and s is amazing now I think epics
done a great job with their cosmetics I
mean it's pretty ridiculous stuff that
often times you do want to get not for
20 bucks yeah I mean their top tier
stuff is 20 bucks Oh No how do I build
oh yeah I don't know if I've ever wanted
downhill fight you can't that's why I
play blackout
yeah then I have to build it's me and
him and our gun skill against each
other's gun skill sans the armor and all
that stuff here's your here's your item
shop and more saying yeah but nobody
saves v bucks like that that is your
choice if you get tempted away by fun
things to buy I think some people can
earn enough where like if you just play
through the whole season you probably
still have enough few bucks to buy an
outfit but you'd have to like really be
tactical about which one you want but if
you did pay $10 you can essentially like
I think you mentioned this earlier you
can easily make it through the whole
season and pay for the next season and
you're still getting the unlocks within
the season it's not like you're not
getting anything you're still getting
that whole unlock tree yeah so this is a
dead fire which there's an unlock for
dead fire he
he transforms as you play which is
pretty cool that's like a new thing and
you spin for them so at least this
cosmetic you can argue gets even more
Flair as you play but I don't know man
$20 for actually it's more than that
right because let's see that's 2,800
that's 25 bucks that wouldn't even buy
you the pick and the skin business-wise
that's they're doing the thing where
they selfie bucks and off increments so
you're never gonna you're gonna have to
go a little bit by 50 if you're gonna do
it you're gonna buy 60 yeah every every
service that has something like that
even let's say I've been playing Magic
the Gathering
arena which is a card game and even they
have the slightly offset like spend 10
because you get an extra hundred gems or
spend 50 and gain another it's like the
old arcade quarter trick right yeah put
five dollars in and you'll get two more
quarters put ten and you'll get a four
more quarter or tokens it was more
tokens than quarters but it's the same
thing right
it's just get you to spend just a little
bit more than you want to cuz you get a
little bit more yeah or play save the
world and earn some v bucks yeah I
haven't tried it but I think there are
also challenges in save the world I mean
yes Aaron you're not wrong there's three
multi players that you get by buying
black ops four so but I feel like tech
people will tend to gravitate to like
one mode more than the others which then
opens up a can of worms of like do you
start do they start selling those as
different things like here's a question
right like if you technically calculate
it it's C they would never do it because
they'll just lose a bunch of money right
but like if each multiplayer mode was 20
bucks I'm probably more likely to buy
blackout for 20 bucks right but I don't
think they'll ever do that because
instead of getting $60 they are only
getting $20 right so yeah I think a lot
of people feel the same way you do
I think a lot of people would just buy
blackout or zombies or zombies or just
old traditional cod multiplayer in which
case they probably need a better
business model for selling you things
inside of each one of those individual
components of black ops 4
King tap is pointing out that this week
they announced save the world is not
gonna be free-to-play this year to be
honest I don't think enough people play
save the world
for it to really matter although you
would think that because of all the
success they're having here with Battle
Royale that they would be able to find a
way to make save the world
wow they they are yeah wow they're
aggressive
they just went right through that house
to get you it's fine we'll take the slur
peace I mean they're making from a
business perspective they're making so
much money off of fortnight Battle
Royale
yeah exactly that I don't even know why
they're bothering I'm gonna save the
world at this stage uh you know I mean I
still think like for some of the folks
there at Epic they probably still like
that mode like it's it's what they first
started working on right and like you
know try a soft spot for it just andis
asking have you summon cube monsters
they just come out of these obelisks so
if you go to corrupted areas they're
fine you also noticed that I got to
killing cube monsters actually gives you
shield so you're not at a huge or you're
at less of a disadvantage when you're
distracted get high yo get high you
always lose when you're low like I think
it's about a hundred percent of the time
I know but that's just not how I play
and that's why I lose in this game
yeah cuz in theory I should have kept
building although I probably have lost
anyway shotgun first pistol unless
you're like really skillful oh this is
old orient seems like aaron moore's into
the if I'm reading right seems like
you're more into the blackout model
where you just pay once and then you get
stuff from the game I mean the old I'm
the old way although like don't they
like they've I know like from a weekly
challenge perspective they really like
start to separate it more where it used
to be like you really needed the
battle past now you not so much you get
like three or four challenges I think
even if you don't have the battle pass
which is is better for sure
honestly ten dollars for a season I
think is very reasonable I don't know
like a lot of the yeah ten weeks it's a
dollar a week answer well you're
probably getting your dollars worth if
you're playing fortnight I mean I always
look at you know spending money for a
game in terms of like my time to play
ratio and like that's how that's how I
that's my value proposition hmm
so like someone that is playing for a
night is probably gonna get big value
out of the battle pass right now the
skins are another like that's another
can of worms because like two skins and
you're like or like three and you're
like near a full price game the premium
skins definitely
[Music]
so yeah I know I wonder do you think
that these you think the cute monster
stuffs gonna stick around or you think
it's all is it only for Fort nightmare
they've been doing seasonal time content
so I'm guessing it's timed okay also I
don't know honestly there's plenty of
time to vents that I wish were around
full time and games but then they're not
special yep like I don't know destinies
iron banner even though I could kind of
argue that it's not special at all in
destiny - but like during destiny one
you know the iron banner was special
when it showed up and if it was around
all the time it wouldn't be special so I
don't know it's psychology things you
want around all the time just become
normal and then they're not fun anymore
I like because there's something about
it being limited time to vent or
whatever that makes you go like oh it's
it's only here for this week I got to do
it that's also why it's so cool that
they're just constantly I would I would
go as far as saying their dungeon
mastering for tonight like they just
constantly changed the map and tell
stories in a way that they don't have to
make a new map yeah maybe I guess they
are in a way making without making a new
map it's really clever like I'd honestly
think that this game is doing a lot of
interesting stuff that other people in
the industry should take note of the
fact that they turned this game on a
dime from save the world and made this
successful I'd respect that
oh whoops I supposed to use three of
these hat loot boxes are gambling so
Super Mario and they manipulate kids out
of their money it's true you know how
the kids do it though I'm a parent and
the kids come to me and they say buy me
stuff right now it's a actually it's not
just for tonight yeah so like if you're
a parent right now a lot of the kids
toys are basically loot boxes they're oh
yeah yeah yeah blind bags and yeah cuz
uh my fiance Cory was gonna get she's
starting to look at Christmas presents
right there's this thing that she's been
getting for her niece which is Disney's
durables yeah and it's just a big house
with like five blind boxes in it totally
so they're teaching them young
children's toys I can honestly say I
have kids and children's toys have
largely moved in the direction of this
kind of stuff like blind boxes
collectibles like we have that as kids
but it feels like it's moved way more
heavily in that direction yeah and so
for us it was like I don't know for me
it was like like baseball cards or like
basketball cards just like that yeah
same same thing though oh that was not
good
so I guess my response to the whole
scamming kids thing is that's kind of up
to the parents like I feel like as a
parent it's up to you to your children
why it's a good idea not a good idea to
buy a ton of things to try and get
something you want out of it I think the
other thing too is like that I'm sure a
lot of parents have experienced at least
once is just like you know you have your
iPad your family iPad or something right
and they're like oh let me can I get on
the iPad to play for tonight and you're
like yeah that's fine and not realizing
like oh my credit card info is totally
saved there because I make purchases for
like Amazon or something you know what I
mean and then like they're like oh I
could buy it I could buy this armor and
then oh did you buy this
mm and be buck you know like why don't
we have this $20 charge where is this 20
dollar charge from it was just your your
child totally have that happen on the
Kindle tablet kids can actually like
factory reset the tablet and when you
factory reset it
and you don't remember to put the like
parental locks back on it suddenly your
kids like elbow-deep in blind bags from
Amazon so yeah it's it's a concern but
also like I don't know I will say
self-control is a factor you can choose
to buy or not buy microtransactions
unless they can for a game advantage
which is kind of what people are so
upset about with battlefront to get her
get her zombies and remorse in the new
battlefield has all the free DLC after
buying the game and it has no battle
pass and I ruined this person was trying
to do their challenge [ __ ] they're
chasing me now David is feeling us on
kids racking up microtransactions on
Kindles
know that crime scene
grown-up his parents didn't really care
what game he was playing but it mate
made him a better parent
to see what's appropriate not my segue
comment for that would be that every
time I played GTA online I feel like the
lock demographic is high twelve year
olds like just 12 year old stoned out of
their minds playing GTA online and I
don't know where their parents are there
was like I see your point though like if
you got away with it as a kid you kind
of know how to not let your kid get away
with it oh what if we just did this nice
your poll tax oh god dammit I spent two
weeks looking for that actually this
might be how I get it finally look at
the dog's face when you're doing that
he's super pissed he's gonna go rip
somebody's limb off I love the
animations of the path it's way too long
that took way too many bullets Aaron
what time is it
we're streaming it is 1203 Pacific good
easier no we're out of the circle if
it's three over there I'm assuming
you're on the East Coast ultra saying
don't swear please I'll try not to
oh that oh dude that's totally a dude
thanks for watching hope you got the
ultra to your kids play for night god
I'm also probably don't let your kids
play GTA online from that previous
comment yes if you don't want them to
hear things bad that's the crack there
crusher crasher all right Steph Amla I
know that's the the bike that runs
through things you could try running
through a work with it right there to
your right
oh oh yeah quad crasher that's what it
is see if it uh see if he'll go through
oh yeah we gotta go Aaron hey we gotta
go make like a tree and leave bad puns
are bad we're gonna kill this zombie
though oh we didn't die actually ultra
saying and my son spent more than eighty
dollars on skins I was so sad oh no in
fortnight
oh now in like one sitting is like hey
dad look at all my skins how did you get
those son super Myers saying playing
video games near kids is not lazy we
have a whole office full of people who
if they hadn't played video games as
kids they would not have a professional
career this is true
funny story man you want me to try to
drive this into this thing right yeah
nope that's a negative go stranger yeah
Ghost Rider
oh dude someone shooting I have no idea
where though
I didn't know you could boost with this
thing did anyone see him was he hella
far away look insane I can't be a 5
added content can i crush him with this
all online GTA 5 online I think oh he
jumped you can't it's out of here GTA 5
online I believe is the most profitable
thing that rockstar has ever done that's
worth it which is why they're probably
doing Red Dead online I think I do
already yeah RDR to online yeah I could
see that that was that was worth trying
I wanted to see if I could run him over
but he just jumped over it I think
you're supposed to save that boost to
like when you're really close I used it
to try to get at them oh yeah this is
kind of new to this was like last week
great there's like tournaments in the
game oh nice I'll generally play video
games in front of my kids and see how
they react to it like I stay away from
the really really gory games but
generally they'll come in when they're
interested in they'll go do their own
thing when they're not interested or
it's too scary for them yeah I would
assume like you just have to it you have
to treat it like a Marvel movie yeah how
can i play a game that doesn't have
blood and as long as it doesn't have
blood or killing a people you can kind
of twist it a bit which is why I like
you said destiny worked so well because
it's an alien it's a robot it's a bad
robot my daughter did fail one time like
she walked up to me while I was playing
a game for work and I was like hey is
the violence on the screen real or fake
and she's like it's real and I'm like
haha we're having a talk right now
so yeah yeah use your own judgement as a
parent when it comes to children and
what they can handle their maturity
their mental maturity is not necessarily
dependent on their age so use your best
judgment
yeah I know I know what you mean crime
it does really only happen during the
fortnight streams I guess there's no SP
it's because I think a lot of people
stream for tonight so they're all trying
to get more eyes on there for tonight
content whereas when we stream other
games they do it most people don't know
the bunkers gone you're in the force
right yeah yeah there was a bunker in
the middle of wait yeah yeah yeah I
grabbed this chest and then we'll go
back the whole reason of me coming here
to begin with was just to get the rib
chilling rib bunker that didn't last
very long
well that's a person they totally just
added a bunker there and it's already
gone he's a gun I mean kids asking for
people to watch my god god oh yes thank
you for jumping it actually made things
easier oh there's another person you've
seen the Marvel movie approach I've
definitely had discussions with parents
about Marvel movies although my kids got
obsessed with thor ragnarok which i
think is one of the best action comedies
in a decade fight me there's a lot of
there's a decent amount of violence in
that where is that guy a lot of Marvel
movies are actually just too slow for
kids like I'm just watch a man on the
wasp yeah that's more for adults though
I feel like just because of the economy
and all that stuff like I don't think a
kid would understand anything Lewis is
like joking about yeah except for maybe
the part where like you know they're
like that was pretty cool the when they
were doing the little escape route thing
it was I'll give you that if I sure they
like just that to the kids they'd
probably be like oh dude dad we gotta do
that all right
is that a person or the monsters hey Bob
Jones I see you too
David says he thinks the bunker still
under the maze they go right through the
maze oh yeah it's over there it would be
over there other oh so there I thought
that was where the crater was but maybe
you're right
Lucan says Mortal Kombat has really good
graphics it did for the day it still
does
don't play it in front of your children
that's not a good one yeah
actually our very fine video producer
Joey did make a potato mode on Mortal
Kombat yeah I was with it on it with him
in which he reduced the graphics to
maybe levels that your kid could watch
if you really are determined to do it if
you haven't checked out potato mode
that's where Joey it destroys the
graphics of some of your favorite games
yeah what did the Fancy's cubes do now
they spawn monsters that you can kill
that drop stuff they also replenish your
shield while you're killing them so okay
200 feet bucks cuz I leveled up so in
400 bucks I could head forward the next
thingy which probably isn't too far away
because I gotta have something I can
earn right there's another hundred crime
scene what do you think parents should
you not like kids play games or let them
play in front of them I can't speak for
myself
I think it's an absolutely personal
decision based on the parents and the
board I would say is just know the
mental maturity of your child and as
long as they can distinguish between you
know fake violence and real violence use
your best judgment i play destiny in
front of my kids pretty much their whole
lives and they've never killed anybody
I'd say it's like kind of just similar
to what you said but I don't know when I
grew up I was only ever like as I was
growing up I was only ever allowed to
play video games Friday to Sunday and so
I would try to limit my child's exposure
to it so I would probably still play
games in front of my kid but I try to
limit it just because I would feel like
it's not fair to them if I'm playing and
I'm trying to enforce on them that they
can't play so I probably wait till they
go to sleep yeah but you know when
they're younger they go to sleep a lot
right like nine maybe sooner depends
eight eight to ten somewhere in that 8
to 10 range I don't know not a parent
yet so I wouldn't know you're married
mantain now so well yeah it's not
official we're engaged but so you're
gonna have to think about that to your
phase
your fiance is gonna want that time life
gets complicated when you're an adult
and a gamer yeah well I joked with her
that so she she needs a lot of sleep I
don't and so I would be watching our
newborn or you know late into the night
I would just play games and then take
care of the baby at the same time and
just hope that the baby's not like
causing a ruckus too much while I am
playing cuz at that age what do they
really know Oh No
tie-dye ninja here's your shadow we're
so dead because you wanted it nice yeah
I wasn't actually oh that guy's got
shotgun yeah you killed that guy oh no
he's got good now don't do it words
asking are there any new spots on the
map that changed oh yeah
so Kevin's back out he blew the island
in three in Twain in Trice but what is
what is the equivalent of his slice
trice trice Obie Trice I don't know
choice I should go a choice Kevin blue
the island in trice and is no longer
moving it around the map their creators
around the map there now hablas that
spawn creatures from save the world i
want to say yeah i think so
killing them gives you shield and also
helps you complete challenges and they
were also dropping some good loot and it
looks like there's craters that are in
new places like a few that crater was
new in wailing wailing wailing woods
yeah I will say when you do kill an
obelisk it does seem to drop something
pretty good what do I hear I hear so
much gunfire and I can't tell from where
yep from behind give me more audio Aaron
a little bit please
Aaron's still going on sure Hayes
relationship ended his video game
streaming career this is true I
definitely don't have time to stream
anymore you know not at home when you're
picking between streaming your
significant other if your livelihood
does not depend on streaming games come
and go but your significant other is
probably there for the rest of your life
spoken like a wise man spoken like a
wise man um yeah it's just like I I'm
already very happy that makes my
significant other is spying with me
playing games like that doesn't bother
her right and like I still raid like
once a week
I told her like almost like when we were
starting a relationship I was like hey I
just wanna you know there's this one
thing I do a week with my friends and if
that probably won't change until this
game dies or I stop caring about it
just so you know and she knew and she
still to this day it still happens and
then she killed him no she didn't kill
me and so it's fine like I set the
ground rule like early and so I'm just
happy that she doesn't mind me playing
games I think it's just harder to like
put myself like at my desk for three
hours or whatever two hours and just
like not really like engage with her at
all like I don't know it's different
like you say it's a different dynamic
once that becomes a reality and I think
most people outside the people that do
it for a living can speak to that and
just be like yeah you know like happens
the only way I could see myself ever
streaming is if I was playing like a
game with her and then she'd be like
cool like whatever yeah that's mine but
like I only stream when she's out of
town so she's actually out of town this
this weekend Bob so yeah you know maybe
get a street you never know there might
be a stream I do random stream you know
the bus also changed active yes the bus
is really cool I like it I'm surprised I
didn't do stuff to the bus like sooner I
know they've added some things here and
there but like I'm surprised that that
wasn't one of the things they like
cosmetic dub but I think now it's like a
thing that you'll probably see like all
the time what's up like team thanks for
joining us we're playing for tonight
fortune
nightmares also if you're somebody who
plays a lot of for tonight and you want
to know about the season challenges we
post those every week on GameSpot just
go into your Google browser and type
season six whatever week , GameSpot and
we'll have your challenge is all keyed
up for you so you know what to do this
is my house you get out of it this is
Tate whose house Jays have no yeah he
had no gun so um
crime scene can't wait to be grandpa and
just play games all day I would be lying
if I said I haven't had the same thought
like I think retirement homes are gonna
be real different for our age yeah so
like you know what's really shocking
sorry I was completely random but I
found out a lot of old people are still
on AOL how does that happen
I don't know I'm scared right now I
don't even know where this guy is guy
thunderbolts saying why won't for a
night work for every phone I'm throwing
out of guess here but probably just
processors whoa what the hell was that
that is a rabbit no no but he like
teleported I'm like whatever that's a
rabbit fine it's fine that was a rabbit
with a revolver and a pet trying to be
real calm collective shotgun properly
QMS how are you doing oh you know what
I've had cozy fires I should have been
doing that you can fully I need V books
oh we all we all need be books not so
that it ends in 10 days is that how long
this event goes I'd have to look it up I
just it went live this morning while I
was coming in on Bart it's a teleporting
rabbit we all saw that right like you
saw him jump to the left or something
and then he warped it back to the right
like instantly and so then in my head I
was like am I gonna have to adjust for
this latency and then it didn't happen
the next time and then he just murked me
although an equally awesome moment for
those who were here midstream was a dude
try the T pose trick on Tay and today
was having none of it I kill any free I
get free kills as much oh I'm lagging
maybe where's the thing that shows your
ping it's not an option five years from
now people think al is a secret society
isn't it already I mean seriously
they gotta be skimming the old people I
just got mail I get ID blows my mind
that AOL is still you know it should be
nighttime all the time by the way
but whatever like in general no like for
the Halloween of it yeah looks cool or a
night we're having we got this one think
maybe the one at shifty I can't remember
Shifty's closer vortex 10 impress us
with your sick thoughts on battle royale
fallout 76 blackout or
battlefields battle royale mode being
delayed all things all things we'll talk
about I'm definitely I'm gonna impress
you if you're looking for
high-quality fortnight gameplay where we
get a lot of kills you're the wrong
place
yeah if you're here for high quality
high quality commentary then yeah oh do
you want to try glider redeploy cuz it's
supposed to happen in all modes now okay
we could just test it out although I
don't want to instantly get you killed
but it is what it is you have to build
up a couple ramps okay I will go to that
tree over there hopefully like you say
stop lagging Tay I know right I don't
know it's your fault you're doing it all
right here we go grab this slurp it up
how to get four night on mobile you're
probably talking about Android I'm
assuming cuz there was we wrote up a
recent article on so it's just jump and
jump right should just be able to jump
and then just fly we're gonna more
shoots this out you're plenty tall let's
see if it works or this is gonna be yes
cool so you can read a player glider at
any time now that came from the store
and 50s mode so I'm not gonna lie I
think is a really good addition to this
game it keeps matches moving quick hey
you keep shooting that oh I don't like I
am so lagging wow
it's me your your fortnight flat hi I'm
stuck oh we killed that guy though is he
local
all right well those are all getting
hitmarkers now oh hello Oh
oh yeah yeah yeah just hit me I think oh
I hit him sweet today we've only
intentionally lagged once in our career
and that was on crota the first time
whoa he's above me all right oh we had a
rocket launcher let's go get lagged no
lag win for you oh this is good for a
shoot
I need that tiny Pikachu you're one year
old you're uh you're doing amazing for
one being on the internet and typing
getting those QWERTY skills down at wine
I hear gunfire
wow I am lagging 100% I am lagging hey
kami super mario says you're cheating me
I know right not intentionally oh this
thing shoots a different arrows to you
seems good where is this person I hear
shock oh there is
I will make sure the theory okay okay oh
yeah feel good I can't even shoot right
now what if they're seeing you lagging
the same way you're seeing them like Oh
got him nice I feel awful right now but
I love how the pumpkin screams the the
RPG pumpkin yeah it's like what you
might call it right Sleepy Hollow is a
can you still ride the pumpkin I know
that was a thing for a while people were
riding the pumpkin well wouldn't it be
like riding a rocket so yes yeah hey
just joined what changes to save the
world I can see why you would think that
but we're actually playing battle royale
this is their fort nightmares event in
which they've incorporated some
save-the-world elements into so many
rockets that a rail so there are
obelisks and now show up around the map
you kill kill monsters in battle rail
they give you lutes complete weekly
challenges and also recharge your shield
as you kill them so that other players
don't necessarily get the drop on you we
got spoiled pumpkin Rockets though so
have some fun other changes are skins
the battle bus is looking at very
Halloweeny and some changes around the
map looks like there's some new craters
and Kevin also split the island in
Christ I think that's what we agreed
upon Oh as a guy as the proper way of
saying in Twain but three sure and Kevin
is now doing something he's chillin over
at loot Lake he's not moving around
anymore Kevin the cube so we'll see if
they're starting the Kevin you could
only offer is that gonna like Kevin oh
right the cube Kevin the cube at least
according to reddit this cube is named
Kevin oh hi
Oh oh nice
crossbow hit that guy - that guy's
credit he had walls up before the
pumpkin even got to him that was
impressive
I'm lagging I'm pretty sure Super Mario
says happy Halloween in merry new year
porta fortress blocked says BW yeah
seriously the players in this game are
I'm continually impressed by the skill
level in fortnight particularly building
people ridiculously good at building
yeah my skill level right my lag skill
Oh only I could turn that on turn the
leg switch on and just like start
teleporting around some people the
vortex is saying is it weird that I
prefer switch compared to Xbox as a
platform in general or for fortnight I
think a lot of people love switch in
general for tonight you'll have to tell
me how the performances I heard it was a
bit jank that long it was pretty Jake
when I played but that was a little
while ago so do you think this guy's in
like one rocket right only one way to
find out there's only two ways to find
out let's do it there's only three ways
to find out hey I know it's not gonna
work oh you'll be shadow I'm probably
killing your name hi the bow and arrow
doesn't work on the Ovilus how's it
going where you are
my switch joy counts keep moving upwards
by themselves I mean say you probably
need to get them replaced that sounds
like a problem not a good one either
Francine we're all gamers should be able
to do our games whenever I think that's
the switches idea I don't know about the
online connectivity if you're on the go
I will say that as a gamer I keep
thinking I want to go on camping trips
but then whenever I go out into nature I
just want to be home playing games so
maybe the switch will allow us to be
both can go camping and play games it
almost seems like every time it's some
type of gold item that'd be really
helpful with the other nice let me
really help with some of the other
challenges there now random in season
six it's good with a cross play
framerate drops more than usual and you
can't compete with a ps4 60 frames Oh
think of how it must be for people on
mobile you think he sees me no he
doesn't see me how did you not hear all
the noise I was making yeah go to the
zombies yeah you want to fight those
zombies we tried playing for night on
Android one time and I couldn't compete
with children's thumbs their thumbs are
way more dexterous than than mine is
what I learned
that's why you need rocket launcher
Aaron and you don't need to be dexterous
at all you just you just shoot it at the
ground old quake style also good rock
just not in to rub controls where you
rub your screen until your character
does what you want it just does not feel
comfortable I'm not into it
all right well we got four kills I think
one of them was like a freebie though or
two of them were lag kills huh we got
some people on channel two think they're
better than ninja add a bowl claim claim
but that's fine if you do go play those
in-game event
we're summer challenge or whatever his
home crossbow feels pretty good actually
not that I I mean I I landed that one
shot earlier that kind of lucky noscope
core but I don't think I'd probably
using it that often
David Dave's in chat here he's our new
an awesome gameplay guy a GameSpot we
made him play for not an Android I did
that that's my fault
and he says never again too bad more
David him a charge down the hall it's
good knowing you you can tell them I
made you do it yeah tell them that he
did not me
play on PC if your thumbs are slow I
probably have this discussion too many
times on streams but man I like
controllers more than I like mouse and
keyboard but you can't beat a mouse when
it comes to shooting and you do a lot of
shooting and shooters so what are you
gonna do Oh game pads I still feel are
superior at any kind of game where you
switch between shooting and doing other
things like driving vehicles that's
crazy
man how bad did valves valve tried to
make a hybrid controller army
Oh Thomas watch that you're doing you're
doing just fine Tay Shore SIA valve
tried to make that hybrid control oh you
son of a-- at least let me shoot my
rockets that's the only way we were
gonna get kills uh I get shot in the
back it happened one of the crossbow
come out come back on ps4 well I would
assume if ya for nightmares if it's in
my mode I don't see why it wouldn't be
in yours but I haven't played ps4 today
to tell you if that's the case alright
this next match is the last match yeah
but for nightmares has been pretty cool
I like that there's stuff like
challenges you can do that are just
specific to an event it's cool to have
some PvE and PvP I feel like and it's
not like those zombies aren't rewarding
because you get stuff out of it so I you
know you can get a rocket launcher you
can get a bunch of stuff so it seems fun
it definitely adds a lot I mean the more
stuff that you can do while you're
playing battle royale the more
interesting battle royale becomes battle
royal is in itself a lot of hiking and
if you want things to do while you hike
it's important to have events and stuff
to find ya and they do a decent job of
like adding new weapons here and there
and like getting rid of other ones or
balancing so like we haven't gotten a
revolver again it'd be nice to get
another one to try shooting it with uh
without a biessings I just ats all the
time which is well that guy's got a
revolver BW agrees the valve controller
is hilariously bad the patron troller is
good though how does crossbow perform a
range it seems to be pretty good Bab nur
I didn't get to use it use it properly
against another human being there but
seemed fine do we go to the one I retail
let's just go to the one at retail
oh wait did we finish that challenge do
you remember probably not
I should track them they they get
suggested now yeah is it all the
corrupted areas yeah so it might be this
one as the last one
although mm-hm yep there's someone going
there so there's a lot of people going
down wow there's like 500 chill out here
oh no someone's here to know we're
committed dang it
alright one more you had the power taste
no no no but look he's probably at 38
okay 60s you know I mean you have that
yeah I know I could have ripped it out
you know I wanted to kill him though
dang it why hike in real life and not
4/9 it's good for your body you need you
need that a vitamin D in your life just
gonna throw this out there but nature's
fun in short bursts oh man he's he's
waiting for the beats drop the revolvers
back is called the six-shooter the
six-shooter I guess it ties into the
character I feel like that that gun
feels better than the old revolver
though from what I remember it shoots a
little bit faster the older Volvo felt
like it shot a little too slow and had a
little bit too much kick yeah but if you
hit though that thing hits like a truck
yeah karai it's gonna be a good time
extra life coming up yeah hey gang so I
remember Battletoads yes hard game all
those games were hard back in the day
TMNT sewer or underwater level paid to
that level you Gannon likes for night
and Call of Duty how do you think the
battle royale is compared as I had a
question for me or for you
show modes we can go back after this and
do most although I think this is
probably earlier oh we can show this
although the only things I saw were
nightmares solo all the way to quads and
then I think the event stuff was at the
bottom people also just joining us one
and see the shop again so we go to shop
too we can do all those things on
way out and get back to the menus after
I die here a horrible death there's no
chest down there daya great death okay
I don't know we peaked at that five kill
just now when I lagged on two people
ghosts and ghouls was the Dark Souls of
my childhood that game was hard to I was
just playing that on the NES classic the
other or not NES classic NES online that
game is hard
jean-luc in our office set up a whole
retro library Count de get this one
already okay this is basically save the
world says deaqon plays its elements of
it that have been added in for I believe
the next ten days is what chat was
saying this dropped while I was on my
way in this morning so don't have all
the full details but that appears to be
true I love the predator rifle kill them
in front of me they're all right in
front of you oh I stole one and then he
randomly killed me and then he died or
someone got me from me you all done all
of you - no no someone got me from
behind
yeah oh so there's your answer crossbow
is deadly from far away
alright let's go check out these things
for you before we say goodbye all three
of you died oh sweet I got it alright go
item shop first there's dead fire this
is the skin that really it just shows
you okay I was about to say he changes
while you I'm surprised they don't have
it in the menu here they have it here
though no do it in a second see so these
things will change as you as you do
damage that's like 30 bucks as a
combination you have terminus is back
think the conclusion was make sure you
see closure there sure what we call it
back to the future children don't buy it
what else did they want to see oh the
modes right the modes do they got rid of
50 my favorite mundo they have disco Tom
yeah praxis tournament do
playground and then your for nightmares
make sense they probably want you to
play the event you know they put in the
time to to get you to do it so yeah
that's pretty much it we appreciate you
all coming by Thank You Aaron for
hopping on the stream with me
yeah thank you for joining us we will be
back tomorrow well not us to but our
fellow video producers here in the
office we'll be back here tomorrow
bright and early I'll just say 7:00 a.m.
I won't say for what cuz embargoes but
you know what to do come back hit that
sub button if you haven't just because
that'll notify you when we go live and
we'll be back Friday as well with Ben
and John Luke they'll be also playing
they'll be playing Red Dead I can say
that because that game comes out Friday
so that's easy but yeah enjoy your time
any last thoughts and where we head out
uh I like for tonight a lot more than I
should but uh looking forward to battle
royale games want to see what blackout
ends up taking away from fortnight just
in terms of making that addictive so
that we can get back in May B's stream
like weekly challenges from that if they
decide to start doing that yeah I'm
really actually shocked that they don't
have them yet to be honest I thought it
was like one of the easiest copypasta
things they could put in now I don't
know how extensive those challenges
would have been but it's weird to not
just see like get assault rifle kills or
SMG kills or grenade kills or something
just cuz even h1z1 had it so we'll see
time will tell I'm sure it's something
there they'll probably thinking about
because they need to give you reasons to
come back I mean the closest thing we
saw in the beta before blackout came out
was they had like a was it like SMG and
grenades only or something they had like
a specific like more limited mode
they've definitely done limited time
they did like for limited time modes in
the beta and I'm in Cana honestly I'm
kind of shocked that in the first what
weeks you I think so yeah they haven't
done any limited time mode and blackout
if you guys are interested in they do it
in your interest in watching it we'd
love to go back and have a reason to
play some more blackout yeah but until
next time I'm Eric that's Aaron thank
you guys for tuning into GameSpot live
and we'll see you next time they take us
out of here you hit that outro button
[Music]